nouveau meurtre raciste en france un
lycéen de montbard en côte d'or français
d'origine maghrébine a été tué hier soir
d'une balle en pleine poitrine par deux
hommes circulant en automobile les deux
meurtriers présumés sont actuellement en
garde à vue reportage patrice romedenne
patrice des semis des dates du miel des
gâteaux du sucre c'est une tradition
algérienne la famille et les amis
reprennent des forces
au moment de porter le deuil j'ai pas de
nom pour ça j'ai pas de nom ma douleur
est grande et j'ai pas de mots parce que
c'est un jeune homme de 20 ans qui est
partie et c'est un crime gratuit voilà
moi m poids ce cinquième d'une famille
de huit enfants il s'apprêtait à passer
son bac de l'avis de tous un jeune sans
histoire hier sur le coup de 22 heures
il discute avec des camarades au pied de
son immeuble
on a vu une voiture arriver par là
allaient et venaient à toute allure
et puis après à la taper une grande
marche arrière
et puis moi devant mes camarades et puis
moi nets ont mené par là on ne sait plus
se cacher dans un coin puis mohamed sur
le coup la panique et la bloquer comme
ça et puis ils ont tiré dessus
cet après midi rassemblement devant la
mairie de sens le maire confirme
l'arrestation de deux suspects deux
voies apaiser les esprits mais pour
combien de temps car sous le silence et
la dignité perse cette colère
qu'attisent une impression de déjà vu
nous accusons tous ceux qui ont inspiré
ce crime et nous voulons nommer
directement le discours raciste
xénophobe et les discours sécuritaires
qui montre de plus en plus que les
immigrés sans et les enfants d'immigrés
sans nez la cause de tous les maux de la
société
après la mairie la sous préfecture pour
y dire ce qu'ils ont sur le coeur et ce
qu'ils ont dans la tête car ils ne
comprennent pas que 45 minutes se soient
écoulées entre le coup de feu et
l'arrivée de mohamed à l'hôpital où il
est mort des suites de ses blessures